where do we go after masters of the
universe revelation part 1 ended on the
mother of all cliffhangers what's a
he-man to do without a sword of power
and what's going to happen next if we
get another season let's dig in
revelation part 2 kicks off by briefly
exploring tila's backstory tila's mother
is revealed to be none other than the
sorceress of castle greyskull who
couldn't stay to raise her daughter with
man at arms because of her duty as the
new sorceress she's clearly distraught
over the thought of not being with her
daughter but she paints a magical
protection charm on her which will
activate when she needs it the most
meanwhile with skeletor wielding the
sword of power he has everything he's
ever wanted and begins turning the
eternian citizens into a mindless zombie
army it's this dire situation that
forces prince adam to try a radical
solution what happens if he says the
iconic words he uses to transform
without holding the sword he transforms
into savage he-man a mindless brute who
has all of the hero's strength than none
of his brains this is because the power
is raw and unrefined when it doesn't
float through the sword so he doesn't
retain his own personality and is just a
being of pure rage he's basically a
blonde hulk however the only thing that
gets through to savage he-man is his
father king randor in the time since
adam's death the king spent a lot of
time wishing he told his son that he
loves him now that he's alive again the
king finally tells him that to his face
it's those words that bring adam out of
his savage he-man persona and point
dread
i haven't told you i loved you
and i never told you
i'm proud of you
after coming into power one of
skeletor's first acts of business is to
make evil lin the new sorceress which
she isn't exactly pleased about because
this keeps her locked away in grey skull
although skeletor gives her access to
the entire universe she's still not
happy that he keeps using her as a tool
rather than as an ally it's difficult
for lynn especially since she's been
with skeletor most of her life but
ultimately skeletor's own short-sighted
goals make her realize that she can do
so much better he waxes lyrical about
wanting to kill he-man once and for all
and it's here she comes to the
realization that skeletor has no real
ambitions for the rest of the universe
outside of his eternal battle with
prince adam then what
what do you mean then what i killed this
version of e-man 2. she even points out
how dim-witted skeletor really is as she
seduces him to distract the villain so
she can take the sword of power for
herself evil lin takes a chance to
transform into an ethereal ignition
warrior however lin is forced to see all
the universe at once and makes the
decision that she should use her powers
to snuff out every living thing
one of the most surprising moments in
the series sees skeletor surrendered to
the eternian forces offering to team up
with prince adam to stop evil lin hang
on did the lord of snake mountain
actually put the greater good ahead of
his own desires for once now that's
character development still the
skull-faced baddie is obviously aware
that if lin wipes out the universe he'll
have his own power stripped away from
him so it is more about
self-preservation rather than
selflessness unfortunately even their
team up isn't enough to simply put a
stop to lin when she raises us up
tourney and dead as her new army a
sprawling battle between good and evil
rages on while adam and skeletor try to
keep lynn distracted long enough to get
the sword of power if there was any
doubt about adam's pure-heartedness it's
dispelled here the hero puts his own
eternal quarrel with skeletor aside
knowing that they need to work together
and once he gets his own powers back he
enhances skeletor back to his own hulk
himself too
there's a very specific reason why he
does this
but why
because i want you to know what saving
the universe feels like
tila is understandably reluctant to
embrace her own magical abilities
largely because she's still resentful
for the fact that her mother never tried
to connect with her all those years
fighting for grayskull that's on top of
the fact that if she becomes the new
sorceress she'll be tied to the castle
and will never be allowed to leave
but she tackles all of her concerns head
on even speaking with the ethereal ghost
of the sorceress about how to make the
mantle into her own she refuses to do it
the old isolated way explaining because
holding on to the ones i love only makes
me stronger
in short she's relying on the close bond
she has with her friends to wield the
sorceress's power in a new way
triumphantly saying
we
have the power
and sure she gets into a flashy fight
with lynn as the two show off their
respective abilities but ila shows the
villain the magnificence of the universe
even convincing her to give up her power
ultimately lin just needs someone to get
through to her softer side
he-man and skeletor should definitely
take a leap out of tila and lin's book
because they revert back to their
typical fisticuffs while the two
sorcerers talk it out but that's all
skeletor wants to be quote locked in an
eternal battle but he-man isn't down
with that it's not
about
us
it's a simple line but he's essentially
saying that their ongoing fight means
nothing in the grand scheme of things
he-man hurls the villain into the outer
reaches of space and all is right in the
world at least for now eternia rebuilds
as it always does while lynn puts
herself into self-exile in a peaceful
location surrounded by the beauty of
life but a final intriguing scene sees
skeletor visit his former acolytes who
now worship an ai called motherboard
this malevolent new entity transforms
into a winged robotic giant before
plunging several claws into skeletor and
filling him with a technovirus it
doesn't look like it kills him so this
isn't the last of skeletor but the robot
displays the holographic symbol of
hordak skeletor's old mentor it looks
like eternia has caught the attention of
a vicious new enemy check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite shows
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you